Ukraine's nuclear energy Chief Petro
cotin has accused Russia of causing a
real danger of a nuclear and radioactive
catastrophe that's after missile strikes
cut external power to all of Ukraine's
nuclear power plants causing them to
shut down on Wednesday meanwhile Russia
says it is in favor of a protection Zone
around the zeppar Asia nuclear power
plant on its own terms that is the power
station is in Ukraine but in territory
currently occupied by Russian forces
it's also been hit by artillery strikes
on numerous occasions we'll get some
independent analysis of that in a second
but first here's Russia's Deputy foreign
minister Sergey ryapkov
as we understand it besides contacts
with Kiev
the iaea is also holding dialogue with
the officials of some Western countries
we hope that this dialogue will help to
convince zedinski's regime to stop the
criminal actions against safaricia's
Nuclear Power Plant
from our side we're doing everything
possible to solve the issue and to do so
without delay
and Elena sokova is the executive
director of the Vienna Center for
disarmament and non-proliferation she
joins us now from the Austrian Capital
welcome back to the day Russia says it's
doing all it can to solve the issue
what's your opinion on that
um I don't think that that Russia is
doing everything it can
um well first of all as reported earlier
the all the nuclear power plant had to
be shut down yesterday because of the
Russian air strikes on the energy
infrastructure in Ukraine
luckily or we Face a situation where the
Ukrainian side and the Russian news
Apparition were able to restore
electrical power to that leads to these
nuclear power plants which is very
important for the safe and secure
operation of this nuclear power plants
however
um the conditions that Russia has put
forward for the so-called protection
Zone that the international atomic
energy is trying to negotiate for a
number of months now
do not sound credible to me well first
of all the the demand is that the
Ukraine uh basically
promises not to reoccupy this territory
and the nuclear power plant and I don't
think this conditions would be something
that Ukraine couldn't accept
um
but
um uh Frankly Speaking the situation
where we see that all nuclear power
plants are now being cut off from the
electricity electrical power which is
critical as I mentioned to their
operation is very concerning the head of
the international Atomic agency Rossi
have been saying for months now that we
are playing over the fire here and that
we're on a brink of having an accident
radiological accident
and I fully agree with that how close
are we to uh what Ukraine calls a
nuclear and radioactive catastrophe what
could happen that could trigger such a
scenario
well uh as when there's no
um liable power supply to the nuclear
power plants themselves which it means
that the its safety systems and security
system only rely on the diesel operator
on diesel generators which have a
limited capacity they can probably last
for several days but that's not a
reliable Supply
the issue here is the continuous pumping
of water that cooled down the reactors
without that circulation of water we
could face a situation that is for
similar to the Meltdown of reactors at
Fukushima and we still remember quite
vividly it was in 2011 the consequences
of that so that's what
um kind of
um
uh catastrophe uh is the potential of
the catastrophe that we're facing in
Ukraine and that's the scenario excuse
me that's the scenario everybody wants
to avoid right this playing with fire
going terribly wrong so why is upper
Regis still being targeted
that's a big question and we still don't
know uh who's responsible we can we have
our uh probably guesses and and
assumptions on who is responsible but we
are in a situation of war and we know
that in addition to regular troops at
least we know from from the Russian side
there are all these mercenary groups
that may not necessarily be taking
orders from from the Russian army but we
don't have a mechanism that can
establish it we do have inspectors from
the international atomic energy and the
separation nuclear power plants but they
are not specialists in assessment of
um you know ballistic uh data and things
like that that could confirm one way or
another and that's not the job of the
agency or inspectors of doing it so we
still don't know
um
but we certainly know that it was Russia
who was responsible for targeting uh the
electric uh infrastructure electricity
infrastructure and the power lines
themselves in the attacks uh a day or
two ago that led to the shutdown of
these three actors so a safe Zone and
having a capable personnel there is
tremendously important do you think this
is something that we're going to see in
the foreseeable future a safe Zone that
that that the Russians and the
ukrainians can agree on and that the
Russians would abide by
um my personal opinion that the
probability of reaching an agreement is
quite low
um well first and foremost because of
the positions of the two sides are too
far apart and for Ukraine to recognize
uh at least in this Arrangement that the
nuclear Cloud plant is now under the
Russian control
in some form of the international
agreement is probably not something that
they are prepared to agree to but for me
the biggest question is that even if
they agree on something
of a protection Zone how this Zone will
be Imports who will be the partisan
forcing it that is the biggest question
to me so to me that even there there is
an agreement I will have to leave it
there
we're running out of time unfortunately
thank you so much
no thank you my pleasure